The fall of the Romanovs, explained like you are five.
Step one, 1894, Nicholas II becomes Tsar of Russia.
He inherits the largest empire on earth,
one sixth of all the land in the world,
130 million people, and a personal fortune
worth $300 billion in today's money.
Palaces, art, gold, jewels, land,
more wealth than any family in human history.
Nicholas and his wife, Alexandra,
live in a world completely sealed from reality.
Balls, palaces, private trains, private yachts,
five children, their youngest son, Alexei, has hemophilia.
A single cut can kill him.
Alexandra becomes obsessed with finding a cure
and falls under the influence
of a Siberian mystic named Rasputin,
who somehow stops Alexei's bleeding when nobody else can.
The royal family trusts him completely.
The Russian aristocracy is horrified.
Outside the palace walls, Russia is starving.
Nicholas does not notice or does not care,
both explanations and the same way.
Step two, 1905, Russia loses a war against Japan.
The humiliation triggers a revolution.
Workers march on the winter palace.
The army fires on them, hundreds dead.
Nicholas survives, promises reforms, delivers almost none.
1914, World War I, Russia mobilizes 15 million men,
sends them into battle without enough rifles.
Soldiers order to pick up weapons from the dead.
Two million Russian soldiers die in the first year.
Nicholas takes personal command of the army,
which means every defeat is now personally his.
At home, Alexandra runs the government,
guided by Rasputin, dismissing competent ministers,
appointing mystics and frauds.
The aristocracy murders Rasputin in 1916,
poisons him, shoots him, throws him in a frozen river.
He dies from drowning.
It does not save the Romanovs.
It is too late for that.
Step three, February 1917, Petrograd.
The workers go on strike.
The soldiers sent to shoot them, join the strike instead.
Nicholas is on his train.
His generals tell him it is over.
He abdicates on a train.
300 years of Romanov rule,
ended with a signature in a railway carriage.
The provisional government puts the family
under house arrest.
They are moved east, further east,
as the Bolsheviks take power in October,
further east to Yekaterinburg in the Ural Mountains
to a merchant's house requisitioned by the local Soviet.
The family calls it the House of Special Purpose.
They are allowed to walk in the garden once a day.
Nicholas chops wood.
The children put on plays.
Alexandra reads the Bible.
They have been in captivity for 16 months.
They still believe they will be rescued.
Step four, July 1918.
The White Army is advancing on Yekaterinburg.
Moscow sends a telegram.
The Romanovs cannot be allowed to fall into White Army hands.
At midnight on July 16th, the family is woken.
Told to dress.
They are going somewhere safer.
They go to the basement.
Nicholas, Alexandra, their five children,
the family doctor, three servants, the cook,
11 people total.
They are told to wait for transport.
They wait.
Then the guards file in.
Yakov Yurovsky reads the death sentence.
Nicholas says, what?
The shooting starts.
It is over in seconds.
Except it is not over.
The daughters are still alive.
The bullets are deflecting off their bodies
because Alexandra had sewn the family jewels
into the lining of their corsets.
Diamonds, rubies, pearls, millions of dollars of gemstones
sewn in as insurance in case they needed money to escape.
The jewels deflect the bullets.
The guards use bayonets, more bullets.
It takes 11 minutes to kill 11 people.
The bodies are driven to a forest, doused in acid,
burned, buried in secret.
For 70 years, the Soviet government denies
knowing where they are.
The bones are found in 1979 by an amateur historian
following old documents.
The Soviet government buries the discovery
for another 12 years.
In 1998, the Romanovs are finally given a state funeral.
80 years after the basement,
the jewels that were supposed to save them
were found with the bones,
still sewn into the rotted fabric of their clothes.
And that's just one story inside Paladin.
It's like Duolingo, but for history lovers.
Download it now and become the most intelligent person
in the room.